tout ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
c'est totalement faux alors qu'un avocat
qui va poser des questions alors on
verra je peux en dire plus que ça de moi
je consacre toutes mes énergies mais je
veux que ça soit très clair depuis je
voudrais fait j'espère encore une fois
que la dernière fois hier l'on ne fait
la revitalisation de l'hippodrome et par
la suite j'ai accueilli des athlètes
olympiques et par un effet ce matin au
fait le budget à midi je vais faire le
mouvement international de la
citoyenneté également de santé mentale
avec l'hôpital louis hippolyte
lafontaine
demain j'ai d'autres activités alors je
vous ai je vous demanderai de respecter
mon processus de maire de montréal
je suis en train de travailler pour la
ville de montréal